Jonnie Anna rabble were born out of a
single spark of inspiration I had this
thought what if we could make a game
about love a game where the bonds we
form with other people were actual real
physical bonds like strands of yarn and
what if you could play as a character
that was actually made from that stuff
and that idea kept growing and the more
I thought about it the more it felt like
a real thing
an important thing the game that needed
to be made
yarn became a symbol of love of longing
in connection it's the red thread that
runs through our lives and ties
everything together the game would be
about reaching out about mending broken
bonds you will play as a little being
made from yarn tethered to something
important at the start of the game and
you would try to make it to the end
without unraveling so you could use your
yarn to reconnect things that weren't
meant to be a part and that little being
became yarny a helper a positive force
is fragile of capable character and to
guide through the world a brave little
thing with a huge heart watches the
world with childlike curiosity and
wonder and accomplishes great things
despite being so small I wanted a
character that would inspire empathy
that we make you care because that's a
big part of what the game is about Karen
I'm connected
I created yarn a when I was on a camping
trip with my family I made a doll from
materials that I basically scavenged and
just started playing with it and posing
it and taking pictures trying to come up
with what the actual game would be like
it was just a really beautiful process I
was out in nature such an inspiring
environment I was basically just playing
and having fun and trying to capture
what that felt like
I had my kids there and with every new
thing that I showed them I could tell
right away if it worked and now two
years later I can look back at that
summer and it's quite amazing to see
where it all led that initial spark of
inspiration has grown into a real game
hours of love and hard work have been
poured into it and yarny is already
reaching people forming new bonds
and that's a pretty great feeling
you